hier in kiew war heute ausgangssperre
auch nachmittags wenn man befürchtet
hatte dass es ein angriff geben könnte
deswegen hatte ich zeit mich mit sören
bartol auseinanderzusetzen sie wären
sören bartol nicht kennen aber er ist
staatssekretär er ist mitglied der
bundesregierung und er hat aus meiner
sicht einen unfassbaren tweet heute
geschrieben er hat geschrieben ich finde
diesen botschafter den anführungszeichen
mittlerweile unerträglich so verhält man
sich nicht gegenüber einem befreundeten
land und vor allem nicht gegenüber einem
kanzler einer bundesregierung die gerade
der ukraine gemeinsam mit dem deutschen
bundestag hilft so offenbart hat damit
den mann gemeint der dort heute in der
runde sitzt anträgt meldet aus meiner
sicht einer der mutigsten tatkräftigsten
und lautesten diplomaten und er hat
absolut recht laut zu sein die menschen
die in der ukraine sterben und sören
bartol und die spd will dass man ihn
applaudiert aber das ist einfach nur
noch wahnsinn was da aus der spd kommt
denn was herr bad hall öffentlich sagt
hört man im hintergrund von vielen aus
der spd sich schimpfen über andere wenig
sie können es nicht ertragen dass er
schon vor monaten gefordert hat dass
dieses land waffen braucht zur
verteidigung dass dieses land verteidigt
werden muss ich finde kümmert euch
endlich mehr um gas kehrt als um andere
melnik gasherd damals meine ich den
mache ich würde es nicht aussprechen der
mal das höchste nicht das höchste aber
der mal das kanzleramt besetzt gehalten
hat da hätte ich fast gesagt der
kanzlerwahl von deutschland gerhard
schröder denn man regt sich in der spd
jetzt auf über andere wenig aber ich
höre gar nichts mehr über gerd schröder
also was ist denn mit der hat schröder
warum ist ja noch in der spd warum gibt
es kein parteiausschlussverfahren gegen
einen mann der weiter als
kriegsverbrecher für einen
kriegsverbrecher arbeitet ich sage lasst
den ukrainischen botschafter in ruhe und
kümmert euch um gas gerd spd herr am tor
jedoch mal direkt die frage an sie
müsste sören bartol dafür zurücktreten
also ich gehöre jetzt nicht zu den
politikern die sofort irgendwie in
sekundenschnelle rücktritte fordern aber
ich finde es eine absolute
unverschämtheit und ich weiß nicht herr
botschafter ich finde es gehört sich
nicht nur dass er diesen tweet löscht
das mindeste ich finde er sollte sich
auch persönlich bei ihnen entschuldigen
ich hoffe dass er das auf den weg
gebracht hat ich finde es ist eine
absolute unverschämtheit ich will das
auch noch mal unterstreichen
es ist ja auch nicht ihre aufgabe
irgendwie der spd oder der regierung in
deutschland zu gefallen sondern die
interessen ihres landes hier zu
vertreten und das gehört auch dazu dass
nicht jeder politiker sind mal alles
uneingeschränkt teilt aber das was der
sören bartol gemacht hat ist finde ich
im ton völlig daneben liegend und ich
habe gehört dass hat für riesig sorgen
und debatten auch gesorgt völlig zurecht
ich meine ich will jetzt hier nicht die
dinge miteinander vergleichen aber ich
erinnere mich an fälle des cdu
staatssekretäre schon wegen ganz anderer
tweets zurückgetreten sind und ich finde
mit so einem das war eine emotion ist es
nicht getan denn es offenbart auch eine
geisteshaltung dahinter und ich finde
eine persönliche entschuldigung bei
ihnen wäre das mindeste gewesen und sie
haben aber ehrlicherweise das
hinzugefügt gerade auch ganz andere
probleme als irgendwelche tweets von
dann völlig daneben liegen den spd
politikern aber es ist einfach
symptomatisch dafür dass das jedenfalls
keine gute haltung ist in der spd und
entscheiden dieser bundesregierung
und ja also was soll man sonst als
diplomat dazu sagen um ehrlich zu sein
habe ich diesen träumen gar nicht
verfolgen können weil es gibt so viele
treffen und so viel zu tun als nur einen
twitter account von den bartl jetzt zu
verfolgen was da läuft und für mich gilt
nicht dass man sich ein wenig schuldig
dass das dass das ist eigentlich nicht
das was man was man braucht man braucht
jetzt richtiges handeln und man braucht
wirklich das was wir erwarten von der
bundesregierung dass sie uns mal
zumindest besser verstehen dass man dass
man sich in unserer lage versucht
hineinzuversetzen zu begreifen was da
läuft nicht weiter so von von berlin
entfernt zwei stunden flugzeug flog
seite und gräueltaten jemanden seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht mehr erlebten
gesehen hat und deswegen wie gesagt ja
wir haben das zur kenntnis genommen
also wenn wenn die regierung morgen da
was auf den weg bringen könnte so
ähnlich wie die amerikaner heute heute
hat werden jetzt an weiden eine
waffenlieferung gesetz unterschrieben
eine milliarde euro allein dafür dass
die verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine
gestärkt wird und wir brauchen das das
ist das was wir benötigen und darum geht
es und nicht wie jetzt
das wasser manche regierungsmitglieder
da quasi im twitter
die zeit verbringen das ist für mich
also nicht zwei sondern gefährlich ist
aber eher wenig hier einmal die
rückfrage weil das hat ja auch paul
ronzheimer gerade aus kiew angesprochen
ist es dein symptomatisch für die spd
oder für andere politiker merken sie das
auch generell am politikern oder auch
bei bestimmten parteien wo sie sagen die
könnten micha ernster nehmen und b ist
der ton nicht richtig es geht nicht um
mich persönlichen und auch nicht um die
person eines botschaft dass es geht
darum dass das kokain in einer
dramatischen lage sich befindet seit
genau 21 tagen und es geht darum dass
man dieser dramatik hier endlich erkennt
und auch dementsprechend handelt und
nicht nur eine zeitenwende einläutete
vor 16 17 tagen um danach gar nichts
geschickt also darum geht es und
natürlich wünscht man sich also mehr
verständnis aber auch mehr führungskraft
hier das vermissen viele ukraine die
gerade jetzt die marke opel wir haben
bilder gesehen ein theater wurde
zerbombte vielleicht viele opfer da
jetzt begraben und und man man man
schaut einfach weg oder man glaubt dass
dieser krieg jetzt so schnell wie
möglich zu ende geführt wird dass die
ukraine jetzt so kapitulation und weil
sie nicht gezwungen wird vielleicht aber
das wird uns nahegelegt dass man sich
lieber ergeben sollte weil man diese
schrecklichen bilder hier in deutschland
nicht ertragen kann und das kann nicht
sein das kann nicht die politik sein ich
habe glaube auch dass es immer noch
dieses gefühl gedichte bis gestern
irgendwo auch beschrieben gehört dass es
ein spielfilm ist den man sich anguckt
also ich kann irgendwie gehe ich das
gefühl nicht los dass es für viele
menschen doch immer noch so einer
fernseh ereignis ist das mit dem eigenen
wohnzimmer wenig zu tun hat wir müssen
aber vielleicht mal die
übersetzungsleistung noch verbessern
also dieses theater in mario pohl wäre
so als würde in münchen des
residenztheaters hat sich in die luft
fliegen das regierungsgebäude was ich
neulich gesehen habe eine der ersten
raketenangriff wäre so als wenn das
hamburger rathaus das rathaus am
rathausmarkt in hamburg kamen die luft
fliegt die bilder von menschen die vor
moan häusern stehen wäre als würde hier
in berlin oder in köln gewohnt zeile
einfach in die luft fliegen weil jemand
beschlossen hat ich terrorisiere euch
jetzt mit raketen das ist ja dass das
macht es nah und ich glaube dass wir das
wir alle in deutschland noch in seiner
in seiner psyche
klemme sitzt von der viele glauben man
könne es ausschließlich damit sich
daraus befreien dass man jetzt mit einer
unglaublichen welle der
hilfsbereitschaft sozusagen menschen aus
ihrem land willkommen heißt hier das ist
aber nur ein teil ein wichtiger teil der
andere teil der auf dem schauplatz in
der ukraine spielt ist deutlich
unterbelichtet und deshalb ist die
forderung die auch aus einer solchen
runde einfach immer und immer wieder
lauter tönen muss herr scholz bewegen
sie sich herr scholz tun sie was herr
scholz lasse sie der regierungserklärung
von vor einigen wochen taten folgen
liebe rot grüne man muss es nicht lassen
die gelben jetzt mal weg lieber rot
grüne ja ihr seid jetzt in der
verdammten situation in einer kriegszeit
in an der macht zu sein dann verhaltet
euch bitte auch so und dieser tweet auf
denen wir da zurückkommen das glaube ich
dass das entscheidende die
dahinterstehende haltung nämlich der
mann geht uns auf die nasen er soll
jetzt mal ruhig sein und er soll uns
nicht dauernd an unsere eigenen fehler
und an unser eigenes versagen und an
unsere eigene
rückständigkeit beim liefern im wahrsten
sinne des wortes erinnern das spricht
daraus auch eine große emotion und
natürlich muss sich der mann der den
verfasst hat
mindestens entschuldigen entschuldigt
erfolg naja aber die haben die
entschuldigung ist aber sozusagen das
ist quasi doppelt tod bei twitter also
erst was schreiben was er immer macht
und sich dann dort ein bisschen
entschuldigen da muss schon ich hoffe es
ist ein brief auf dem weg ein wenig und
übrigens an alle ukraine denn die hat er
damit gleich mit beleidigt ja und man
muss im übrigen auch mal sagen die
dahinterstehende haltung jetzt zu sagen
ich paraphrasiert das mal so wie er zum
ausdruck bringt der herr meldet geht uns
jetzt auf den geist da muss ich mal
sagen ich finde wie sie sich
diplomatisch nach häusern und wie
gefasst sie sind ist ehrlicherweise
mensch ich glaube anerkennenswert wenn
ich das vor augen führe die vielen
interviews die ich auch von innen
gesehen hat die gespräche wenn sie
berichtet haben wie das ist für ihre
familie das invest hat tagtäglich
erleben das muss man mal zum ausdruck
bringen ich finde was im moment in
deutschland ein problem ist und das hat
man heute gesehen ich meine wir haben
eine aktuelle stunde gehabt überhaupt
nicht zur primetime zur lage in der
ukraine
der bundeskanzler redet nicht er sitzt
auf der regierungsbank studiert seine
akten annalena baerbock redet dann und
hat im prinzip auch da werden
vorbereitete reden vorgetragen und ich
habe nicht den eindruck dass da die
emotionalität aufgegriffen wird die
jetzt nötig ist und wir erleben im
moment wenn ich den punkt machen darf so
ein stück weit so eine normalisierung
des krieges es ist ein stück war nur
dass viele jetzt sagen ja das ist jetzt
so wie der tägliche brennpunkt der nach
der tagesschau zu corona kam jetzt gibt
es seit das update was es in der ukraine
und da kann ich sagen das ist das
hochgefährliche wir müssen es so wie sie
es gesagt habe nämlich genau übersetzen
und uns auch vor augen führen was das
heißt auch für unser land lassen wir
noch einmal zu brands heime in
abschalten das ist ja seine these und
ein paar partien haben wir noch nicht so
wirklich debattiert und das ist gas
gerhard wie du ihn anders was können wir
denn tun gegen ihn also was sollte
deutschland jetzt tun wie sollte
deutschland gegen agieren und vor allem
jahr auch die spd seine eigene partei
ja das klingt jetzt so wahnsinnig rabiat
gegen kuhn ich glaube einfach wenn eine
spd sagt das ist alles so schlimm was
der ukrainische botschafter tut dann
frage ich mich doch moment mal also ihr
habt ja lange zu gast gehalten
eigentlich über all die jahre wo er
schon geld gescheffelt hat für wladimir
putin wurde er schon dass in seinem
tresor stecken konnte für die raketen
die ja gerade runter regnen lässt auf
das land in dem ich gerade bin und dann
waren sie plötzlich alle auch wieder
ganz baff mensch jetzt fette zu putin
und dann hat lars klingbeil der spd chef
das fast gelobt wo ich dachte moment mal
ja okay wenn er das hinkriegt gut und
schön aber man hatte schon die ganze
zeit so das gefühl das ist doch eher
eine pr-aktion und das hören wir hier
aus kreisen des präsidenten aber auch
andere manager hat sich dazu ja klar
geäußert und ich frage mich wann sagt
jetzt die spd also wenn du bist dann und
dann immer noch bei rosneft und bei
gazprom arbeitest dann strengen wir ein
parteiausschlussverfahren an das kann
doch nicht sein dass alles sanktioniert
wird alle sanktioniert werden aber der
ehemalige bundeskanzler weiter kohle
scheffeln für wladimir putin und dieses
geld ausgegeben werden kann wenn man es
mal übersetzt für diese raketen die
hierunter regnen wer und auch dass er
jetzt in diesen tagen das geld einnimmt
also ich bin jetzt nicht
absolut zuletzt also auf dem letzten
stand der details in welchen branchen
gazprom und die anderen bezahlen aber
die vorstellung dass jetzt irgendwie das
märz gehalt gekommen ist
deutlich fünfstellig in einer zeit in
der der absender sozusagen ein
kriegsherr und das brot und und diktator
ist das muss doch nimmt ich muss ich
muss ehrlich ich kann es einfach nicht
verstehen was mit gerhard schröder los
ist der muss verrückt geworden sein also
mir fällt auf dass also der grat seines
verrückt werden sozusagen sich in der in
der menge der instagram post seiner frau
wieder findet ihr also quasi jeden tag
irgendwas postet und dann wieder löscht
und es wird auch immer und wäre was sie
da macht er aber irgendwas muss mit dem
mann passiert sein denn es muss doch
einen sozialdemokraten und ich dass das
würde ich immer noch sagen das ist ja
doch das ist doch der sozialdemokrat
gehört nachdem es gelungen war
sozialdemokratische ideen in die mitte
zu rücken mit sinn unter die leute der
muss doch jetzt sagen mein herz schlägt
noch so weit links dass ich mich
wenigstens von einem
kriegsverbrecher soweit distanziere ich
kann es macht mich eigentlich richtig
verrückt dass ich es nicht verstehe denn
ich fand den mann mal klasse und jetzt
finde ich ihnen im gleichen maße also
mindestens irritierend bis schrecklich
aber das katastrophal um das nur zu
sagen ist auch der umgang den die spd
schlägt damit ich meine dass er den
wichtigen natürlichen aufgebrochen also
die augen davor verschließen wir werden
mit ihnen nicht reden was er da gemacht
hat und ich finde die bundesregierung um
das man in den details herauszuarbeiten
es ist eine unverschämte die sagen wir
wussten von der reise nichts wir haben
jetzt auch durch die berichterstattung
der bild zeitung erfahren dass die
personenschützer von gerhard schröder
bezahlt vom steuerzahler dass die mit
russland waren und solche reise sind an
der reihe und auch keiner
da durch es ist davon auszugehen dass
täglicher sicherheitsbeamten da bleiben
und die ministerin wird uns nicht sagen
ob sie es vorher wusste oder nicht